so i just spoke with your director kelly
and she said that your bond with kelly
or your bond with abby on set was
immediately this mother daughter bond
was that experience like for you oh i
feel i feel really lucky that i got to
work with abby that she was margaret i
can't imagine anyone else being margaret
so it was kind of instantaneous i mean
she's such a pro but she's also just
such a kind loving human
you know she's got both somehow i mean
she's wise beyond her years and so it
was really easy to fall into
that relationship and and find a
friendship as well which i think is
reflective of
the relationship in the film you know i
think
barbara
doesn't want to be like an overbearing
mother she wants
margaret to find her own way and uh so
so it felt it felt reflective of that i
hope that well we are in vegas and a lot
of people like to gamble what would you
say is the biggest gamble that you took
in your career that paid off
um
i guess when i when i was after i did
the notebook and mean girls um i i
did a series called slings and arrows
yes
in canada and uh yes
i know it well
[Laughter]
and that was uh
just so great to come home and and i
think some people on my american team
side didn't quite understand you know
why i wanted to run back home and do
that at that time it was such an
exciting time but
and it was
amazing yeah it was such a great
wonderful experience i love working at
home and
and i think it turned out well it turned
out so well so
you know no regrets no regrets no listen
all of canada is obsessed with you so
including myself so thank you so much
you